hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer and today
is a very fun special day because we are
going to be
developing our first site our first page
using only html and css
and to make things even more exciting
we're actually going to be coding out
a replica of one of wix's um
websites because wakes you know is a
platform for people trying to create
websites for their businesses and things
like that
and so you know they have a whole team
of developers to create these
templates for you guys and so you know
what i want to show that with just html
and css we can do just what
they are doing and so we'll be coding
that
out and every single link
you will need for this tutorial is in
the description box below so make sure
you check that out
it will specifically have the images
we'll be using
and a link to one of the code snippets
we'll be using as well
and so make sure you check that out so
let's
see it so we are starting right
from the beginning everybody so we have
our index.html
file in our style.css file
so just so you all can get you know
excited about what you're going to
create
we are creating basically a dupe
of one of wix's templates for
websites and so this is
the template they have and we're going
to recreate this
we're only going to do this first half
because it kind of goes down a ways
but so we're just going gonna do this
first half of that
but let's get to it so the very first
thing you have to do
is declare the doctype and in this
situation it is html because you know
that's
the way of the game but um we also have
to declare
the language which is english
then that'll go all the way down there
then we
need to create the head tag which
is really all the information um
needed by your browser to convert
everything
properly to convert your html properly
so we need to say what
character set is being used
which is utf-8
we also need to link to our css
and so i think css
and then by pressing tab then we have
all of that there
so the href is linking to style.css
and that is the name that i chose for
our file
because i knew that that would be the
default if your cs is named something
differently
then you'll just have to change that in
here into you know flower.css or
anything
like that and then finally we need the
title
tag which is what the browser will be
named and so
let's say wix imitation
so very first thing that you should do
though
is now that the css is linked
we need to make sure that the link
worked
and so we do this hold on before i get
there
let me make sure we have our body
because it's gonna
be affected by that so we do this
by saying something like body and then
changing the background color so
background color red
if our links work correctly
then boom it is
red now and so
let's make sure let's like really double
check
yellow boom so whether you
started you know developing five minutes
ago or five years ago
always do these smoke tests to make sure
everything is linked properly
if we had a javascript file we would
also do this with javascript console
logging a message and checking
that that message appeared in the
browser but you know that's neither here
nor there because that's not what we're
doing right now
and so let's look
at the website we're trying to imitate
so it is divided into different sections
so let's call this section one which
has more the title of the company
section two which has more about what
the company is about
and then section three which has its own
three little sections kind of like a
contact us kind of thing
social media learn more all that so
let's make sure we have those in here so
we need
name a class and so let's just call this
section one
for you know simplicity purposes and
then
do another div so div is yes how we
define
our sections
and then we provide class names and you
know
id names to make
grabbing these elements easier later on
when we are trying to style them
and all of that let's say additional
inflow
info boom
okay so now let's go back
into section one it looks like we have a
the title of the company a you know
sub title and then a little tiny
description so titles are typically
h1s and let's say our title be
the next great
engineer then our h2
our business will be software
engineering
and then in h3 we can say
solving today's
problems with
let's just make it all fast with
tomorrow's
technology boom
let's make sure that shows up boom
okay i'm gonna say boom a lot
i do this when i work to y'all so then
the who we
are section it looks like there's this
box right here with you know a little
header here
and then more information about the
company
and so because it has a little text box
of its own let's create another
div and we'll call it
intro because you know looks like
they're introducing themselves there
and so we'll have the h2
and we'll say we
are developers driven
by the want to see
everlasting change
and then the other portion was more of a
paragraph
now i can't think of a paragraph on the
top of my head so i'm just going to copy
and paste this
and i'm going to just indent this this
different way
just so we can really see the separation
of the paragraphs better
and so now that is our second section
done and if we refresh
boom there it is so i'm going to
now go into that
last section so that last section
remember y'all it had
three different sections of its own
so we're going to create three more divs
and so we'll say work
and then the next one
will be social media
social dash media no spaces y'all
and then the last one
let's say visit us
okay so now
let me give you all a second to catch up
oh
i see i'll catch up and i scroll all the
way to the bottom
[Music]
okay so now let's refresh this oh but
you know no text was added but speaking
of text
it looks like each section has its own
little box
over here and so let's create
three more divs inside the divs we just
created
and so the work one we'll have a div
class equals let's just make them all
just title
we won't put too much information in
them
and so because they're all the same
well because we want them to all be
formatted the same
oh i cannot spell title i'll have the
class names
same named the same way that way styling
is just so much easier
title there
and so the title for the first section
will be
our work
then the title for the second section
will be social
media then lastly
h3 is visit
us so that's really it
everybody like as for html
this is really all we need to do so i'm
going to
give y'all a second to catch up again
[Music]
so now it is time to style
so i went from index to style.css
so let's take out this portion because
you know we don't want
to be blinded by our work today
but okay first thing we need to do we
need to apply a
myers reset so
let me go in here myers
reset oh there we go
and the link is within the description
box we're going to copy and paste
all of this first in our css
because what happens is the browser
automatically formats
things you did in html for you
and so we want to undo all of those
changes so that we have full control
when we are styling
and so i like to add a comment saying
end of myers reset
just so i know where my code starts and
where theirs ended
and so comment is created by this slash
and star and then say anything you want
and then star
and slash then that's how you end the
comments then you can start coding
i used the shortcut of command question
mark or the command you know
slash i'm not sure what the
i think you can do control the control
question mark is how you
do the exact same thing in windows
i'll have shortcuts linked below as well
so let's get into the css y'all
so let's refresh this
yep you see how the myers reset
took away all the previous fonting and
everything the font sizes and the
all that yup that is why we need that
so let's say we have the
section one
and let's tile that first on it just put
a section section one
so every time we have a class in css
we select it by putting a period first
so whenever i put a class here
to style it i would put period then what
i named it
this tells css that we're grabbing stuff
from
you know index.html
and so what we're going to do is set it
at a height of like
1000 px pixels
then let's have for now the background
color be
black just so we can see some division
there
let's have the text align in the center
and let's see how all of that did
refresh and boom
the color of our text
needs to be white so we can see it
so now let's check and boom see that
you see that and then everything else is
on the bottom
okay so let's create some margins so
that everything is contained in a
certain area
so we'll have the margins be of the
entire
body of our browser the body is
literally
just everything every section every
single thing
so and i'll show you why in a second
but if you go to index.html
see everything we put is within
the body so
css is no different so when we say
margin
if we refresh now on the top is 20
pixels and on the sides is 20 pixels
okay so now let's see
let's have a padding
on the top of about 20 percent
so we want the text to move down about
okay there we go because if we see
back in this browser see this text
wasn't all the way up here
and you know there do you see how the
margin
looks about the same same here
here's the margin and then the text is a
little ways
down and so now let's
make sure we change the size of each of
the
headers within section one and so
because we want to
change the headers to in
specifically section one this is how we
say that
because if i put something like font
size
up here then everything in section 1
is changed to the exact same font size
but we don't want that
so font size let's say 90px
then section 1
h2 let's have that be
oh let's say 50 50 px
and then section 1
h3 let's have it be
35 font size
of 35 ps
now let's see how that looks boom
see that we are getting it together
okay now let's do more or less the same
thing
to everything else we'll worry about the
more specific items
later so now let's go
into section 2
aka who are we
so let's go down
so let's have it so that the height is
also
1000 px
then let's make the color white so we
can really see
which where the last section ended and
where the new one begins
let's let's see let's see how
that looks like for now
okay you see that there it is the height
looks quite small though what did i say
oh i said
100 1000
boom see that
1000 px and so now
let's tile the intro if you remember the
intro
was where we you know introduced
ourselves as a company
color is black
there we are i was like why can we not
see it
okay let's make the color black let's
make it so that
it floats to the right because if you
saw here
remember how everything was on the right
hand side
so let's make it so that the same
applies
here and the width goes all the way
across the page so let's change the
width
to 40 percent
so it's 40 of the page and float
to the right okay
now let's check and there it is okay
perfect
now the intro had its own items it had
an h2 and a
paragraph so just like how in section
one
we're going to specifically target those
elements
we're going to make it so that it starts
a little bit down
the page and it's not sticking up to the
top like it was
we'll make the font size nice generous
50.
let's for now see okay see how
everything went down
that's because we changed the margin and
okay things look pretty good there so
let's do the same
with the paragraph intro
entropy margin
dash top let's say 20px so it's not
sticking to that header
font size will be a little smaller since
it's you know
more text and then
let's add text shadows to all of these
just so
things pop out of the page a little more
so we'll make the color black
and i'll copy and paste it
so that this applies to the header as
well
so let me give you all a few seconds to
catch up
[Music]
now let's refresh and there it is
okay it's really it's really out there
but we'll
get more into it soon so this is section
one
section two
and you know what let's move this
because you see how this is taking all
the way to the right
let's move that a little more to the
left
so padding right
with 13 do you see what i did i went
back to the
general intro section
and added this styling right here
padding makes it so that things move
without changing the margin margin
is for the outer section here you'll see
it better here
margin is for the outer section and then
padding is for the
inside section like here and so if we
refresh
you see how it moved yeah okay that's
better
because here you see how yeah it's a
little bit
more inside it's not center which is why
i didn't make it center
that's why i manipulated the padding
instead
okay and now we have our last section
which is going to look
more like this
okay
so now let's create that last section
which we named
additional info so i want to make sure
we're all on the same page
that is this div right here so we had
the
overall div for the third section but
then
in the third section there were three
other rectangles in there and then each
rectangle had its own little box within
it
so this one is going to you know have
more layers
than the other ones so
we named it additional info
right here additional
info
and so let's see
um first let's actually let's keep this
here for now
because if i do this now it won't make
sense so let's keep this here
and let's go to the
other three sections which was titled
the
work section we see that classes work
then social media then visit
us so let's go in there
instead so we're going to
have it so that all of these things have
similar um styling and so
i am selecting all of them at once
instead of repeating things
so by doing this we are selecting
everything at once
so let's have it so that the width
of each box is 33 of the page
because if you remember here
you see that they're all pretty equal
so the width is yeah it's right here so
let's make it 33
of the page we're using percent so we're
sure it's equal sizing
and everything and we don't have to go
into the specifics of the exact
pixels for the size with height we will
be specific
let's say about 600 pixels
and then let's create a margin
so that it doesn't stick to the section
above it which was section two
so let's say 10px which is responsible
for the top part of the margin and then
5px is the sides so making sure things
don't stick to each other
what makes make it so that each of the
text
is all aligned in the center so text
text line center
and what's next let's make the font size
let's make it a slightly generous 35
pixels
the um the color of the
of the text will be white
and let's see what this looks like so go
back in here
and refresh let's make the background
color something
just so we are clear let's just make it
to you
just so we're clear where we are
okay so we see how the three sections
were created
but do you see how they're stacked on
top of each other yeah
we can't be having that and so what
we're going to do
is add this property called display
flex
justify content center let me double
check
hold on oh you know what i'm missing
everybody
here remember i said that this wouldn't
make sense yet yeah
that's why so display
flex and then again justify content
center
so let's refresh there it is you see
that
so the reason we have to put it in here
as well
these items the word social media and
visit us
they belong in this section and so we
put
display flex and just right content
in this section because we're saying
everything
else that's in here yeah make sure that
everything's lined up if it fits that's
what display flex is
and then just by content make sure that
everything
is centered that's why when i put it
here the titles moved to the center
but then if i put it here then each
individual
div is moved to the center
and is side by side so
let's look at it again these are our
three sections
the next great engineer the info
and the like contact us you know
kind of page so this is very exciting
we're really seeing
headway and so now let's fix the styling
of the titles within these rectangles a
little bit
because they need to be a bit further
down so
dot title let's have margin dash
top be 50 so this is going to move it
about 50
down let's have the height
of the title part let's make it so it
creates its own little box with this
with a height of 90 pixels
and a width of about eighty percent
of the size let's make
the little boxes background color be
black
and then the color of the text
be white so if we see what that looks
like
see that so we created little boxes
within
these large rectangles with a height of
width of about was 80 and then
the color inside is
white so
if we go back over here
[Music]
and let's make sure we
justify the content to be
centered
i'll display flex
there we are we need the display flex
for this
portion because we're seeing now
everything within the rectangle
let's make sure it's i like to say like
let's make sure it's flexible you know
what i mean so
display flexible and then
now let's have it so that the content is
centered now that you're flexible
be center so let me give you all time to
catch up
okay now very quickly we're going to
add a little
part here where we make it so that
the title isn't sticking to the top so
we're just going to add the padding
again
title of h3 padding of 30 pixels
if we refresh boom now it's not
sticking to the top anymore so here is
the basic
outline we have now so kind of
like we're technically kind of like you
know
there in terms of formatting now let's
add
the cool features and the cool images to
make it really nice and clean
so you see how like when you scroll into
this wig site it's
things look all like they're floating
and things are crisp
and everything yes let's add that
so we're bringing it all the way back up
to the top y'all
so let's go back up here
and you see why i like the comment of
end of meyers reset because i know
where i was at now so
looking at let's start right at section
one
right over here so let's add a
background image instead of just a color
so background dot dash image
and if you pick up the link i
posted in the description
just add that here so background image
is
going to be a url
and then you're going to put the quotes
and then just
paste the link in there okay so
background image
colon url and then it's going to be
parentheses and then
quotes and then you put the link and so
if you go back
into your page you refresh
boom doesn't that look pretty
boom we're gonna make this more beatable
soon but yeah
so i used this site called unsplash
to get these images so unsplash is great
this sounds like you know
an ad but this isn't i'm really just
trying to teach y'all
this um site is great because it
provides images that are just
so high quality high resolution and
they're completely
free for use you can add them to your
own actual
apps and videos and everything and
you know you would have no consequences
at all for not you know linking them or
anything like that
so if we even let's say like search
restaurant
you see how like nice these pictures are
and they're always like such
large pictures so that they're not you
know blurry once you add them
in it's blurry to load but not to
add them in or anything so i really
really
recommend this and i've linked unsplash
below as well
but so all the pictures here are from
unsplash
and so what you do once you find a
picture you like
you click on it and you can either
download it
or open image in new tab and then copy
the link that's what i did because we're
just doing a quick you know
tutorial but in other cases i would have
downloaded it so no
really really really recommend and so
anyway anyway to make this more really
readable let's add a text shadow
to what we
wrote in there so it'll be
negative 2 then
something like this and
let's see what happens
when we refresh see how that's a lot
easier to read it pops off the page more
so definitely recommend adding text
shadows when possible
so then oh well
okay this is important so
you see how the width wicks
when we scroll it has this floaty effect
is because the image itself isn't moving
it's because it's the text
that's moving and so here the image is
moving you see that
and so we wanted to have it so that only
the text is moving
so let's add the series of code here
so that it looks like that so
background attachment is
fixed you know you want it fixed to the
page
background position
center just you know just center
everything
background repeat background repeat
it's there because if let's say a
certain image doesn't actually fit
the page what css what um
css will do is basically repeat the
image over and over again in the browser
but we don't do that
we were saying if it doesn't fit that's
fine don't repeat it
and then with background size we're
saying
to cover the entire
container in this case the entire div
and so let's look at what that did
you see that cool right right
so now it has that floaty effect like
the wick sight it has that
same float like feel so we're going to
add the same thing
in the second section but first
let's fix our font so let's make the
font family be more like a sans serif
that's also kind of basic but actually
i think fonts is like the thing i'm like
most lacking in
i'll get better let's say letter spacing
so let's make sure each letter in the
titles is paced out by three pixels so
the letters are merged together
so and then let's have it so that the
font weight
is lighter so we can have it bold so let
me show you bold
bold looks like this see that
and then if we say lighter
you see that is thinner so that's what
that's doing now
let me just add something to background
image
because we want this to be as readable
as possible so let's just darken the
image a little bit
so we're going to add a linear gradient
here and have it be
rgb a 0
0 0 which is the color black and then
0.1 opacity then
the a again
with the zeros
because we're doing it black again and
0.3
oh i need another parenthesis
boom save that go back in here refresh
see how the image is a little darker so
now it's easier to read
so now let's
add this these items to
the other sections so let's go to who we
are so
let's have this background image
and this is the photo
we'll be using this 2
is linked
in the description box
we'll have it so same exact things
background attachment is fixed
background position
is centered background repeat is
off or no repeat and then background
size down here
is cover
save all of this i'm going to give you
all a second to
fill that in
okay so let's see what that made
our site look like oh you see that y'all
isn't that cool isn't that cool
so i'm going to add a margin so that
there's a little space here
so
margin dash top because we want the
margin to be specific to the top of the
section
30px now
let's look there we are you see that
because the width sites yeah each
section had
its break oh this one didn't
huh but i like it better with it we're
keeping it sorry y'all
let's make the text color white
so let's take this out
there looks much cleaner
and now let's get to
the let's see the bottom
sections and then we'll be done
crazy right crazy crazy so
we're going to add a virtual college
an image to each of the individual
sections
so we had the work section
dot work
so background image
will be this link
leave the url
and then attachment is fixed
back on position who's gonna be cinched
her
ground position is going to be center
background repeat no repeat
and background size
it's going to be cover no not auto cover
oops what that looks like there
see that
so now let's do the same thing with the
other items
so you can really just copy and paste
this
down so command cop
command paste
there the other sections were called
social media
and visit us
and so all we have to do is change the
url
so that url is
this one copy paste
and then the visit us url
is here
you see that we really just did the
exact same thing so dot work
but we copied and pasted it three times
and then we just changed the background
image
so let's look at our creation
look at this look at us y'all
wow see that
how professional that looks so now
this is these are just now little tweaks
so you know how when you hover over
something that's clickable
it's the cursor changes to a pointer or
the color changes
so if we go into wix's site
you see how the color changes to white
and now we have the pointer guy over
there
let's do the same here let's
change that here so let's i like making
things like grouped together so dot
title h3 so let's say dot
title hover
we want the style to be this when
hovered so background color
ground color
we want it to be black but like
kind of transparent so rgb a0
0 0 then like 0.7
yeah something like that let's see how
that looks
refresh wait how am i saying black my
goodness
what am i doing because it's already
black
i meant for this to be
here and then this
to now be more white white is 250
255 if i recall
and then let's do a 0.7 let's see
ground let's see what it looks like okay
refresh see so it's not like so harsh
black now
it's you know more taint down okay
now let's make sure that the text color
changes on the hover so we can still
read it
color black
cursor is a pointer cursor colon
pointer very very simple
that's one thing i like about css they
try to be very simple sometimes they
don't succeed i will say that
but they try so that's appreciated
i don't want the white to be too white
let's make it 0.5
to be fresh okay
so now if we start from the top this is
what we have
you scroll scroll
and boom one two three so before we're
done
we're so close i'm just going to change
a few things here
specifically you see how close these two
are matched together
yeah i want to change that so go back up
here
to where we started coding it was
section one and
these are h2 and h3 of section one
so let's make it so that the margin
oh margin top 30.
okay
i'm gonna do a little more y'all let's
do 60
and then let's have the h2
have a margin that's top about 15 px
boom boom boom oh my goodness i
misspelled
problems why didn't you tell me
that's the one thing sometimes i want
actual dialogue you know
i definitely want to do a live soon with
you all so you can
do this all as a little party but for
now
not yet but there we
have it everybody
we went from no page at all
to this wix imitation isn't that so cool
so so cool just like this one
go through they have videos instead of
images
but so excited to have done this with
you all
[Music]
so there we have it everybody i hope you
all
liked this tutorial and i hope you
learned a lot
about really how simple things can be
with html and css and
what all you can create making a dupe of
a wick site
alone please let me know what you think
if you'd like to see
more videos like this of tutorials and
code alongs and things like that
leave a like because you know i won't
know what you want from me unless you
hit that like button
so hit that like button and i look
forward to seeing you all
soon so bye y'all